I think my favorite part a whole press
conference was obviously what's coming
up next to a South Park yep that was a
fantastic girl because I thought it was
going in to watch dogs they had the
snowdrop engine stuff so it could be the
division and it was just yeah they did
some dated some sesame dig yeah they
went straight for Kanye like yeah just
insulted his game about his mother going
into heaven yeah which is like savage
just grew completely and then just went
straight into like taking apart Marvel's
phase movie plan which is that yes
what's causing the civil war between the
kids oh yeah I mean some of it as well
it was uh again the south park near the
knuckle yeah humor that we all know in
love but also I just love how much the
the title of the game lends itself to
innuendo like that poor the poor dev he
was saying so what's new with the
fractured but can I can we see more of
the fractured butthole like guarantee
they named it that just so that everyone
had to repeat it over oh yeah we're
laughing to themselves so hard when they
named this game like famous but like
what we're seeing on the screen now is
they've revamped the combat system yeah
it looks it looks like we were
suggesting like it is completely being
redone instead of taking most of
obsidian did it's it's designed to be
more of an active game because you are
playing superheroes you get to pick
classes you can do different like super
super power moves and it looks really
cool and really fun the first game stick
of truth was genuinely funny and it's
very difficult to be genuinely funny in
a video game few companies can manage it
yeah and it was it was hilarious it was
crude Purell on the way that we love
south park being so like this looks like
it's going to be along the same lines I
am mega excited about this game well up
for it yeah Dave well like I said before
I'm not a big fan of south park but even
this game made me laugh yeah I might it
might be the thing that gets me in two
more south park and I you said the
combat looks a lot more interesting than
the last game did as well yeah not just
all three standing on one side you get
this movement involved Scott I might
save some of my opinions for an angry
Twitter rant but I
it's looking better than the first game
I appreciate that they've like added
some depth to the combat it's looking
like it might actually be pretty fun and
I do love the the whole premise of it
basically being like a big giant rip on
marble yeah I mean especially when he
said oh my god your DC like that was an
amazing burners own the whole Black
Panther bit wow it was WOW Jess they
really went places with that we are
there and yeah yeah this is almost the
point of being like a bit spiteful and a
bit like crossing the line ish but I
know some people argue that's what's up
out does best and I don't know I know
about that